as companies look to meet growing
customer demand you'll need to scale up
fast in order to stay ahead
that means deploying new applications
and moving critical business data to a
new cloud environment without breaking
the bank
but getting terabytes even petabytes of
data to the cloud can be tricky
constrained bandwidth security concerns
extended downtime any of which can make
your task more stressful than it should
be that's why IBM cloud introduced mass
data migration a physical data transfer
method that enables you to quickly
securely and affordably move large
workloads to the IBM cloud with just a
few steps on the IBM customer portal you
can request a mass data migration device
be shipped to your location of choice
that's right Hawaii Japan your old high
school's cafeteria space um maybe not
those last two when you receive the
device simply power it on
select the data you want to move and let
the mass data migration device take care
of everything else
don't worry all of your data is
encrypted so it will be safely stored
once complete use the provided shipping
label and mail the device to the
originating data center when received
every bit of the data is immediately
offloaded into your cloud object storage
bucket where it's easily accessible and
if you'd like you can freely move it to
a new application in the IBM cloud after
everything is transferred the device is
securely wiped of any trace of data you
had inside whether it's freeing up
on-premise storage space consolidating
data bases or decommissioning data
centers mass data migration makes it
easier to get your job done at a low
cost jumpstart your move to IBM cloud
for more information or to order go to
IBM comm cloud mass data migration
[Music]